hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
Mark Ellis joined as always by the
incredible the wonderful uh the the Tea
Leaf dropping do you spill the tea and
then you drop tea leaves she's G me a
lot of hints about stuff I haven't seen
yet and jacn Coy knows how she's
torturing me particularly this time of
year with the certain films that come
out around this season
yeah and normally they're like Awards
ones but yeah I I dropped a little
knowledge on this one around horror
which I was just going to say to Mark
I've had a lot more horror movies I know
I'm looking very Texas Chainsaw Massacre
today but you look you look like you're
about to go bobbing for apples you know
what I mean like it's it's uh it's been
more there was a time that I avoid
horror movies there was a time and this
the movie that we have today was this
time I was very much realizing I was
like oh why was this like so not a part
I was like oh you didn't do this back
then and movies like this is the reason
why uh well back in 2009 when this film
came out our guest was bu a zygote I
believe uh he is just look this guy not
only can tell you the chronology of Saw
and the franchise in its entirety while
he's drunk there's a YouTube video
proving that he also has a great horror
maze that he's putting on in New York
City uh here in a couple weeks and this
weekend you can find him on the Wanger
Show karaoke I believe it's their fourth
edition oh yeah and uh and you know him
as the host are pretty much it he is our
good buddy first time in studio for Eric
striffler yeah yeah so excited to be
here I've been on a couple times or at
least once for sure uh uh on Zoom so
it's very nice to actually be here
thanks for having me you were the kid
the adorable young pup who just loves
the mummy with Brendan Frasier that's
right that's what it was that's what it
was you wore your mommy shirt I believe
that's right do you know how I didn't
have anything for S do you know how many
bisexual girls you took that one off the
chart for like seriously you should you
should very much honor the fact that
there's an entire cohort of these that
are mad that you got to do that episode
like seriously there's a lot of people
that wanted to talk to Mommy and you
were the you were the crown Jew you were
the crown like you should own it and
Lord it over them I'll take it now I
will I'm not going to say there was
quite as much demand for guest clamoring
to talk about saw six saw six
specifically six specifically and I'd
like to just recount a little bit of the
text message chain that went on between
Eric and our producer Brian Perez wait
wait I'm sorry before Mark does his
announcer bit let me give youall a
little background we have the actual
like screenshot of the text message this
is very watching the simoc cast here it
is this is very meme worthy like we
could put this on the YouTube I hope
y'all do all right Mar if you know Eric
which we all do and love uh this is how
you take advantage of him because he his
mind works faster than the normal human
brain was meant to do and so you can
just tee him up with a little question
and then he'll just send you pages and
pages of of real Just Thoughts stream of
Consciousness so Brian an innocent text
produced outwhere by the way he just
texted me this out of you want me to
give you your dings
ding here we go ding hey buddy question
what's the most underrated movie in the
saw franchise ding oh great question dot
dot dot my first thought is six but
that's a fan favorite so I don't know if
it's technically underrated three is
also a fan F but maybe generally
underrated in the sense that most folks
are probably like they should have
stopped at one no they should have
stopped at three Ding and TBH spiral was
better IMO than most give it credit for
even though jigsaw isn't in it l
Mao I'm going to go with six final
answer and here we are and that is how
we arrived at 6 oh my God by the way the
reason why I was laid on the Dig's side
not that I don't have rhythm I was too
busy laughing and trying not to ruin the
tank that was really good it's like you
and I practiced it almost like we have
some on air chemistry man as you know
jacine and I never practice anything
it's all live for you folks the Dome sa
six is a movie that is 39% rotten which
I saw and I'm like okay Eric's going to
come in here and fervently defend the
movie come to realize it's actually the
second highest rated saw film by Tomato
Meter only the original saw tops it and
that's still rotten at 50% so before we
get into Saw 6 and whether Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong about that I mean look
you got 39% rot and 47% audience score
these are good scores by saw franchise
you know numbers by six entry in any
franchise it's like okay sure what is it
about saw that like on on the whole is
just all these films and now we got the
new one coming out why do critics not
like these movies Eric you know I don't
know I I think first of all horror I
feel like is tough it's very subjective
what scares you what doesn't right are
these even horror movies technically I
guess like it depends again what you
find scary if you find ghosts scary and
that's it then these are not horror
movies to you right um but also yeah
they're gross I feel like they were kind
of like breaking the rules and making
the new rules in a away because it kind
of launched a new category of movie
unintentionally you know like with
hostile and stuff like that things just
getting more and more gritty the quote
torture porn kind of thing yeah I didn't
want to say it but you can say it I I I
I feel like these movies tow the line
very well the first saw is not that at
all it's a psychological Thriller it's
it's a Sundance Film it was like a movie
movie you know what I mean and but so
point is like they started to devolve a
little bit and this one I will say
elevated it as they were going yeah kind
of going down and I'm a huge fan so you
know everything I say it with love I
love all the movies uh but it was kind
of going downhill and this one brought
it back up a bit which I saw some of the
reviews mentioned too yeah and I I I get
surprised by these kind of movies jacqu
because I don't seek movies that are
this graphic as far as like the violence
and the blood and gut like literal guts
go but every time I stumble across a
soft film and I've seen a few not all of
them but a few I'm like these are really
cool these are fun they they are
definitely disgusting they're bloody
gross but there's a lot to get into with
the song movies and I felt the same way
about six so I'll kick us off here and
say yes I think Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
I think this movie should be higher uh I
do think this movie is better than it
seems this spy brought me back such
memories I just wanted to tag team on
what you were saying about why critics
didn't like it the thing about the saw
franchise and no I did not watch all of
these but I did watch a video that gave
me the Beats of each one a lot of yours
was it by Eric a lot of yours uh yours
part of the plethora but I guess what I
would notice is what was going on in
movies at the time and this movie came
out and then it kind of got wrapped up
in the Final Destination sort of like
big horror Gore gag thing because what
the saw franchise has done is reflected
the horror Sentiments of other
franchises at the time and this was the
one that was happening at the same time
as Paranormal Activity and because this
one wasn't received as well sort of in
that I would say like every time saw did
something well somebody would come after
it that would make that look a little
bit more ridiculous like the
psychological Thriller after you do
Final Destination it looks like it's low
stakes now they got to up the stakes and
so now they do one that kind of returns
to form but it's like well now we have
these people that are doing these more
psychological gags and that one it's
like they always felt behind the
eightball and what the audiences were
wanting at the time feels like superhero
movies now yeah like oh you're flying
around we got that we're done with that
it becomes sort of an arms race where
it's like we just have to be like either
Bolder or scarier whatever else it's
funny bring that up jacqu because saw
six actually opened against Paranormal
Activity like literally the same weekend
and that movie was such a Jugger nut and
it did because saw six came out I think
it the budget was $1 million it ended up
making $68 million worldwide which is
huge return on profit but it wasn't the
return on profit that Paranormal
Activity was because that was made for
like eight bucks and made like $300
million wor return to all the cameras
literally buy a camcorder and that's
that's the budget for the first PA movie
so Eric I feel like you're going to be
in agreement with jacan and I the Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong about SAU six because
that 39% it just ain't high enough for
me no I mean it's it's wrong especially
if you just factor in like that saw is
at what 50% I think something like that
the original saw 50% are you kidding me
come on it's an actual really good movie
uh and launched you know look at the
franchise it launched it's unbeliev
that counts for something obviously
there's something there right if you
movie the formula there okay look if you
look get saw and you just say okay let's
take that 50% number because most other
first entries in these classic horror
franchises are fresh El street is in the
90s Halloween is in the '90s so if we
take that 50 and we make it now now all
of a sudden you're saying the sixth film
in this franchise only fell 11% so there
should be around the high 70s it should
bring up all of them is my point yes yes
also when did Rotten Tomatoes really
like start because I I wonder also oh
well we just had our
25th cuz I was going to say so it was
kind of in the early days Halloween
everyone has to go back to review it
yeah yeah right and you have those
Nostalgia goggles maybe as well I mean I
love Halloween saw people were doing it
at the moment there's still contemporary
reviews that we get I'm like Tim Ryan
who we're going to talk to in just a
moment would be sad if I didn't like he
would be like Jacqueline you didn't
correct him we oh no that's fair yeah I
know but um it's usually this just a
guess I don't actually know usually it's
about now depending on how big the movie
is about 50% but most of our old movies
people aren't reviewing them like you
know when you get something big like
obviously Citizen Kane and some of these
ones where you have hundreds of reviews
it's one thing but most older movies
like you'd be surprised how few reviews
are out there that are contemporary and
how few people go back and review it
again that's kind of what I'm thinking
though is that like this had more people
maybe having that in mind you know what
I mean you wouldn't if you don't like
Halloween maybe you wouldn't even go
back and review it see what I'm saying
whereas with this it's like oh it's a
new movie I'm going to it revenge is
still 0% % and it's because I haven't
gotten around to review I believe it's a
dead zero I haven't I haven't reviewed
it yet cuz I it's getting a number it's
getting a real integer once Mark Ellis
is done with it because that fourth
entry in the JW for I keep pushing to
have that movie on the P it's probably
never going to happen but I would love
to talk about Mario Van Peebles in it
Michael Kane Micha doesn't he have that
famous quote about it haven't seen the
movie but the house of bought is
beautiful or something like
that apparently it's Dreadful something
like that uh we are going to turn it
over to our buddy Tim Ryan in just a sec
here I do want to give some shout outs
to the website our great editorials that
we have at Rotten tomatoes.com you can
check out all the Saw movies ranked by
Tomato Meter so again the OG is number
one saw the last chapter is last at
number nine at fittingly 9% so we'll see
where saw 10 fits in that lineage and
then we also have how to watch the saw
franchise chronologically I believe our
team did this Stone Cold Sober unlike
the way Eric did it in his vid but sober
drunk however you want to figure out how
to watch the Saw movies in order because
it is a little different than just 1 2 3
4 5 6 uh let's go to Tim Ryan now
because Tim is our expert review
curation manager here at Rotten Tomatoes
and he's going to tell us what the
critics were saying at the time way back
when on the dawn of Paranormal Activity
and this new saw film how the critics
were feeling about
[Music]
it we covered the original saw in a
previous episode but today we're doing
saw six so did the critics have to say
about that one in a rotten review Rob
Nelson of variety called the film so
frighteningly familiar it could well be
called saw it already however in a fresh
review Wesley Morris of the Boston Globe
wrote who knew that the franchise's
creators would eventually find a plot
twist that made sense the Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus reads it
won't earn the franchise many new fans
but sa six is a surprising Step Up For
What has become an intricately chrisly
annual tradition so that that's the soft
franchise do you like the way brutality
feels mark back to you I'm not saying
intimate Tim Tim's got a future in in
jigsaw if he wants it that that was
pretty good and menacing their Tim thank
you for that uh we usually do a synopsis
and I think that today Jacqueline it's
going to be fun to have our guest have
to do the synopsis dud how much time do
I have so let's go ahead and let's go
and transition into movie talk and then
we'll do a synopsis by performed by Eric
strify I actually prepared for this
synopsis I'm glad he's going to do it
but I prepared for this I was literally
getting ready the only thing I will add
is whatever you end up saying I doubt
you're going to add the one thing that I
found to be the most important about all
of it and I just want this movie about
this movie I know that you will not add
this note but I'm going to so there's
one one specific moment comes to mind
but it can't possibly be no it's not a
moment oh okay never mind not a moment
Brian hit the music let's find out
yeah like I prepped interesting I
prepped for this interesting Eric
strifer the the role you were born to
play tell us what Saw 6 is about uh okay
so I'm going to keep it to just what Saw
6 is about goty there is well because
there is uh detective Hoffman Jill tuck
all of them are like in the background
doing the soap opera which I think is a
big reason why people love these movies
every year you got a new episode of the
soap opera and and I I think soap opera
has a negative connotation but in this
way I mean it in a good way like it was
it was fun to keep up with what was
going on so let's keep it to just this
movie we have I think it's William uh is
the
um is the main character and we're at
this point in the franchise they're
basically just repeating saw three where
it's like one person going through and
seeing other people in their traps and
stuff which I think like the only time
it changed up again was maybe spiral or
something um but so he's going through
he is uh he works for an insurance
company he is in his overall trap
whatever because he Deni he denies
people insurance and this got real
political this movie none of the other
movies were like that and so I actually
appreciate that thought that was kind of
cool um you know it had something to say
and I think one of the reviews might
have said that as well and uh he has to
go through and uh you know again it gets
muddy at this point but like are people
in traps if they're not allowed to
escape technically you know what I mean
like you're supposed to be able to
escape your trap but he's going along
and finding people that are that he has
to basically decide who lives and dies
one of which is a guy that's in there
because he smokes right right I mean
jigsaw is getting a little petty at this
point I I'll be the first to admit but
he's got he's sort of forced into that
conundrum that all the Saw movies love
to do and then there's a lot of like
really interesting and unique intricate
torture devices corre along the way
corre so he's going along the way while
the whole soap oper is going on in the
background which is lovely we can get
into it if you dare uh the uh the the
William story line is yeah he's going
through and it's a bunch of employees
from his insurance company and jigsaw is
really upset with all of them you know
just in general like we can all
understand the the concept of like you
know an insurance company and and
dealing with that
but specifically he was denied uh
insurance and you find that out a little
bit later on um I will say something
that's interesting about this one is I
think it's the first one where jigsaw
you know how usually it's the puppet on
the or you know he just you just hear
the voice or you see the puppet on the
TV you see jigsaw for this one because
this was like his most personal game yet
technically because it was it was him
directly uh dealing with the guy who
denied him Insurance uh so I thought
that was really interesting and that's
another element that kind of elevated it
and uh and at the end are we spoiling
this thing is do we assume people seen
it yeah I think we can go ahead and
spoil it uh at the end you have one of
the better twists in my opinion uh two
things really going on a family twist
where you the whole time I just love
about the Saw movies early on in the
movie uh the the the mother and son they
see William on the TV and say this is
we're here because of your father and
you think that that's her husband the
whole time going through it turns out no
it's a guy that he their father the
father is a guy that he denied Insurance
to and those little intricate ways that
they say the line saw to you'll find him
in a safe place and he's in the safe
like there's so many sneaky little
things and that's that was one of the
best I think in the franchise some of
them you get it before they reveal it
because you're like all right why did
they say it's so weird like that this
one was perfect so that's a great twist
and then to get back into the soap opera
what I think is one of the best saw
endings of all time with uh with the
reverse bear trap being escaped by uh
Hoffman you get all that yeah you got it
I did and jacqu was going to add yeah
what the beginning
scene the actress who won it yes it was
on a show that I watched even though I
didn't watch Saw called scream Queens on
VH1 it was a contest for her to be a
part of it and the sister won and there
was so much drama about the sister
winning on the show on the so you
actually watched it so did you see the
movie at the time or you just saw and
you were like I remember her yeah oh
that's awesome that was literally it I
was like I watch scam Queens I yeah they
did a lot of those like when the contest
be a part of it like this was in the you
know who wants to be a VJ like social
media was starting up as well I remember
being aware of that and that was one of
ironically I I think that the
promotional campaign that that was
worked against saw because it was like
oh that's where this franchise is now
now we're just doing reality shows and
you can win apart like you know back in
my day being a heart movie like all that
crap she was actually good in it and she
was actually she's actually really good
in it but they assumed that she was
crappy in it because of everything that
happened with and I was like actually
yeah she's great like she's like tell
the folks that shark NATO I didn't marry
those two pieces of knowledge at all
until I saw our notes this morning cuz
I'm watching the movie for the very
first time last night and I experienced
it and I'm like oh no that's a great
opening sequence I had no idea that it
was like somebody wanted contest to get
in there I'm like these are these are
really well- trained thespians that were
looking at here and she's got that great
scene later when she's like look at my
arm yeah yeah yeah she's excellent um so
we didn't see it in theaters Eric did
you see this in a theater not only did I
see it in theaters I went every year cuz
you know the the thing it was if it's
Halloween it must be saw there you go
every year which another another thing
that was just so exciting since the
original did you see that so the
original I did not see in theaters I was
a little too young I guess I caught it
at home you were four I caught it at
home yeah I caught it at home but
starting with the sequel saw two I
saw the previous movie and the next one
they did a double feature every year so
I would go and rewatch the previous so I
saw five before this one in theaters and
I would go with my friends my dad uh
would bring me CU I I yeah I was like by
this point I would have been 2009 was it
so I'd have been 18 but uh for the first
few years I couldn't go you know what I
mean like I had to go with the parents
so my my poor dad had to go and watch
these family bonding trip but it so
lovely of him he drove me and my friends
that Thursday night whatever at midnight
kind of deal it was that was back when
it was still at midnight actually
remember it used to be you had to go at
midnight now it's like 6:00 it's like I
kind of miss midnight I missed like you
had to be there at midnight on Thursday
you to see a movie before Friday now
it's just all these showtimes 7 it on
Thursday come on you soft movie goers
but so yes I did see them all in
theaters um and I uh I think they were
trying to prevent child delinquency fine
no well it it didn't work it didn't work
yeah now these kids are getting inated
movies earlier cuz they knew kids were
the only people that were out that late
and they're like this is not good kids
in their dads turns
out cool band name kids and their dads
kids and their dads I like it an album
or confession how how many of the song
movies had you seen up to this point cuz
I I just basically got the first one and
then I was lucky enough to see the uh
the the most recent entry that's coming
out in uh this weekend I think my heart
is beating so loud in my chest worrying
about you ACD saying not going to say
anything I know how I didn't even text
you after I saw it I knew saw saw movie
yeah yeah you didn't text me you know
what you you know what I had sent to me
a video of you saying you saw it from
Christian yeah right I'm not I'm not
giving away my secrets you know somebody
puts a camera my face that's fitting
that that's on brand me trying to scare
me yeah absolutely keep me on edge no I
think I've seen so I saw the one with
Chris Rock CU they said to me spiral I
saw the first one I've now seen this
one there's another one which is the one
with Carrie Ellis when he comes back
seven yeah I've seen the next one yeah
yeah so insane but can't even get into
that so I've seen this one and the next
one and the only reason why I watched
the next one was because he was back and
it was
terrible it's Terri listen we're here to
talk about SAU six we're here to talk
about SAU six and I can say that the the
selling point of this franchise for me
is again I'm not like a blood and guts
guy necessarily but I do enjoy inventive
spins on hor and I think that the
torture devices the traps are always so
ingeniously planned like I really get
into hey how are you doing this what's
the mechanism going to be like how you
get out how would I get out the
psychology of making those choices of of
having this poor guy I mean I guess you
know he did some bad he denied a lot of
people coverage and now he has to like
figure out which which person he's going
to keep alive who he's going to execute
and it's just like man you're talking
about a torturous device these things go
physical and they go mental and
emotional it is tough though because
like I said before you got the one guy
that what he smokes yeah you deserve to
die you know what I mean like what it's
it's a little rough and then there also
was in one where like this was right in
the time when the surge General was like
C in Cas I'm like that's fine you know
like but then there isn't there also a
young guy who like his crime in life is
like being single or something he's like
you have no friends you're a loser you
deserve to die again this was the this
was he was picking between like the
older woman who had less life ahead of
her but like a loving family and the
young guy who has all his life ahead of
him but is like a loser yeah you get rid
of the young guy I'm just saying the
risk of a of a dude like that left alone
Grandma's not going to hurt anyone this
was 2009 though this was 2009 different
now is that scarier no in 2009 they just
did this guy this guy had just gotten a
keyboard and a YouTube account and he
was just starting to troll people that's
that's what this guy did or could could
they have murdered the next uh Bo
Burnham because he got a keyboard maybe
a musical keyboard and was about to
start his internet career Bo Burnham
didn't come about that at 19 Bo Burnham
was like eight privileged white in
Connecticut and that just
continued we love Bo Burnham on this
show you're welcome you're welcome
anytime I do no he's admitted that by
the way I'm not saying anything this
proves how much of a Bo Burnham fan he
talks about his very idolic and
privileged life and then he went and did
comedy and realized I'm awful and then
he got better I'm thinking about this
movie franchise as a whole but also we
can talk about this because like as you
get further down in the war obviously
the original jigsaw toin Bell that that
character has passed away but you he
died in two movies technically he dies
in three and four if you if you remember
four at all basically he dies at the end
of that one again he seems kind of like
Kenny from South Park in these
occasionally where it's like we're just
going to bring you back for this or for
this or for this like this recording or
this video but it it there is enough
there there is enough of his sort of
fingerprints on this movie I think to
make it feel like he's he's a real
genuine part of and not just showing up
as like service kind of thing especially
with him being on the tapes him visually
instead of puppet that adds a lot puppet
Fair it's nice to see him uh can I also
say too um as a Picket Fences fan cus oh
good call yeah uh I will admit though
like he was like hot in the 90s like he
was 90s dude hot and this movie made me
question things like a Eddie Winslow
Darius McCreary shows up in that's the
opposite it I was not checking for Eddie
Winslow before I didn't know he was
going to show
up good in this good in this he was in
one night in McCool's yeah yeah he did
some stuff you know who also leveled up
of the black older brother tro uh from
The Cosby Show if we can dare speak his
name uh Malcolm Jamal mourner y him at
45 Morris Chestnut wishes there you go
well that's a stretch Noom M with that
beard no okay Chestnut is like the high
bar for but he's been that the whole
time and so it's like now like whereas
in like with like Malcolm has gone up
this the this listening to this is a saw
trap for some listening to Jack and I ra
how hot these men from the 80s and 90s
objectify every black man in Hollywood
considering this show has a 100 episodes
and this is the first time we've gone
here you know what else looks really
good now Julio white looks really good
yes yeah I saw him on a weed commercial
and I was like Ur you you're finally
home guess what the weed is called no
wait uh
Stefan no wow that would be better wow
that'd be good purple Urkle kid purple I
like did I smoke
that I smoke that my God you need to DM
that to him at least did I smoke that I
bet he has well there's a lot of smoke
and flashing lights and other things
when you do these mazes you know that
they have and I know you're you're
setting one up
so you can tell us about your your
haunted house that you set up in New
York but through the lens of like CU I
know saw has had like those Mazes at
them parks in the past have you done
those they had one at Six Flags this
year how intense are they cuz I just did
my first maze this year and it was it
was freaking Exorcist themed of all
things you know how that movie just gets
into my soul did I did that and I did
and there was a stranger things maze um
and uh and we did The Last of Us and
like walking through these mazes and
they're like filming me walking through
it
see every godamn Twist and Turn I'm
shrieking I am I'm not and and and even
the people who aren't supposed to be
scary cuz they have all these like like
like Druid Jawa looking the security
guards too kind of startle you because
they're not supposed to be seen and
they're just pointing but all I see is
this tiny little wizard pointing
somewhere and I'm like that's even
scarier than the other stuff I'm afraid
of okay you are not getting the full
experience cuz I've done that video by
the way I appreciate the Rotten Tomatoes
makes you do that video now cuz I did
that video to 2 years gray did that
video one year they do it cuz they see
the camera like you're not getting the
real Hollywood Horror Nights experience
you're getting the Hollywood Horror
Nights with a 4k camera experience so
they're targeting you
like when you go through it's a little
easier like when you go through normally
so I just did it in Orlando Horror
Nights uh uh with with a couple friends
and yeah we're just going through
normally and yeah you see like you know
you see them up ahead sometimes whatever
but but so the the important thing to me
is just getting to be like inside of a
movie yeah like scares are fun but for
me it's like it's being immersed in like
a cinematic stranger things I mean like
you get to be in stranger things I don't
know how it was in Hollywood but in
Orlando it was fantastic well no I mean
because I go in there and my first
thought is like because I know the
camera's going to be on me the whole
time it's like all right Mark you know
how to handle this just H it up a little
for the camera make it a good bit that
went out that went out the window the
first turn I took I'm like get me the
hell out of here because the worst thing
for them is for you to go through that
and not look scared actually like the
kiss of death so just so that doesn't
turn out bad they like go up for it well
they got what they wanted I have the
opposite they have these necklaces that
people that maybe have sensory issues or
just don't like to be touched can put on
which is actually even better because
it's like you can be right up on
somebody having whatever happens to you
happened to you but they don't touch you
oh I love that I love being in the
middle of a haunted house where you're
not a part of the you're just hitting
your little life call Button like hey
don't no like they just like it's you're
not at the front of the group or the end
of the group is just on you like it's a
little like a light up necklace and it's
like basically like they just don't all
right I'm talking to production because
that was not that option was not offered
to me well CU that would not that's not
the video have have you done a saw
before Jack uh no so when I did it it
was Purge movies that was the other that
was the other reason why I didn't want
to do it like The Purge time that they
were doing a lot of those this Blum
House stuff but like with with saw I
imagine like are you in a trap because
the other thing that I don't want to do
like like The Mazes are fine you walk
through them you get the crap scared out
of you for a couple minutes I'm not I've
never done an escape room so there I
guess there's a chance that I would love
it like they even offered when I was
working in Vegas this past week they had
like this saw escape room experience you
could do and unfortunately it was like
at night maybe fortunately for me it was
at night and I had shows so I couldn't
go do it but it was pretty much like an
escape room themed by saw is that right
have you done those things is is that
right one of the saw Escape rooms it is
up my alley I don't know what I'm
waiting for I feel like if jigsaw were
to like just like take the three of us
prisoner Jack and I would be like
looking at Eric like hey dude how do we
get out of like well I would be
immediately analyzing all the words he
said to find what what what did he say
that was a little weird I mean I have a
test for you okay oh here we go you're
leaving a theater mhm there's one car in
a parked garage and it has the door open
and you're walking by the door is open
what do you do as you're walking by uh
get kidnapped by a pig do you like but
do you like are you that's the only
thing that's going to happen I'm not
looking I'm immediately looking the
opposite direction of the open door me
and you will be fine yes I'm getting
kidnapped by the you're like cuz if you
are curious as to why that door is open
you're not making it to the end of the
last you know what I mean like I don't
need to be curious about that door well
right right the good news is they don't
make you they don't make you escape
usually like in in the haunted houses at
the at horor nights and stuff like that
but you do go through rooms and see
characters so maybe you would see I
think her name was Simone the scream
Queen's character uh maybe you know
waving her arm around or something like
that they jump out at you with that and
it's so cool just to get to see that
stuff the puppet you know you hear the
voice you hear the music we haven't even
mentioned the amazing music it's it's
very very cool to be I think it was
actually maybe like 2009 or 2010 that
that I went to the first it might have
been the first saw maze at har Nights in
Orlando something like that a long time
ago and uh and it was just so cool to be
in the world that I knew and loved so
well yeah there's like winks and nods
too that aren't necessarily meant to
scare you and and what I appreciate
about overall is that and and this would
go all the way back to the first one
certainly this entry that we're talking
about today is that there is a it's not
parody but there is like a satirical
element to all it's very dark satire
it's you know it but it also it does
have like a little bit of a political
message but but it's never going to let
any of that stuff get in the way on it's
not going to let that stuff get on the
train tracks with this Caboose that is
chling that is there just to show us how
inventive you can torture people and
make question their decision Mak we're
still going to kill people in a gruesome
fashion just a slight
Spoonful political thought fun to see
them get out of the traps too sometimes
no matter what it's interesting to see
the Trap work uh the Trap fail or the or
the person succeed you know what I mean
like it's there's there's always
something interesting that can be done
with it yeah I was going to say like how
do you sell saw P how do you sell non-sa
people on this franchise have you given
up sh you don't I was just to say you
really don't good was
like the first movie I could probably
sell somebody on uh but because I'm like
it's not like the rest of them it is
really not as brutal it's it's more
psychologically brutal it's not as
visually Brut uh brutal uh as it goes on
I I mean I have to admit it is much more
visually brutal it just is um the the
they latched onto uh the the gore and
the torture and the traps and stuff more
than I don't want to say more than but
yeah maybe a little more than the
psychological aspect well I mean it's
not even falling prey to you know what
you have to do when you're a horror
filmmaker or a company and you're like
we're making multiple sequels this thing
you every every franchise has had to do
this the nightmare in Elm Streets uh the
you know Friday the 13th Halloween The
Kills have to be more inventive there
has to be more blood there has to be
more jump scare what whatever the thing
is that your franchise does well you
have to increase that with each
subsequent chapter even if
chronologically they're not all stacking
up in the right order and that becomes a
problem yes for sure because then they
they want to have like a big big crazy
trap that turns out to be like 10 years
in the past and it's like wait you did
that and then you like scaled down and
then you went back up again you don't
always have the same budget you know
just as far as like like an evil genius
you know sometimes your years are lean
sometimes the crypto Market didn't play
out in your favor sometimes the stock
market and now you're just like
basically we have a tricycle and that's
spoken for because that's what the
puppet rides out well the tricycle yeah
is a onetime purchase yeah yeah that's a
you can reuse that you have it I would
reuse my favorite trap in this movie was
the I loved the wheel the carousel yeah
one of the it was so good and it also
was so different than anything that I
had seen in any of the other saw films
because again I'd already seen saw 10 by
this point the shotgun Carousel yeah so
good what a great like IA like again
it's evil it's it's diabolical but I
mean tip of the cap but also I love that
funny at the end with the guy like you
look at me when you're killing so big
clearly like intentionally huge going
for it you know what I mean but like to
the point of it being funny like it's
kind of fny scene and you know that like
that Kevin the director you know he's he
edited all the Saw movies up until
moving into the director's chair for six
so he probably in in his mind I can only
imagine he's like look we got to do some
send UPS here and there right you know
like we got to have this guy go big and
it works so well the guy at the end is
great what do you do in that situation
when you're pitted against a mom and
she's got a family and she's like got a
great rapport with this guy who's making
the ultimate decision here what do you
like I'm watched this movie last night
and I'm like like there's nothing I
could say I'm pretty good with words
there's nothing I can say that's going
to save my life in that situation I mean
in truth the girl that wanted to fake
being pregnant was the best idea that
was the best idea that was the best idea
called out or the only other thing that
I would say is she's not pregnant is a
lie I would have been that guy I would
have been no she's not is a lie they
can't check on it's like no I live by
myself but I literally have my parents
who I pay for their thing they would
literally be destitute and homeless
something like that like you have to
have somebody relying on you that's the
only way to get out of or maybe say
nothing almost maybe like the least
annoying you're definitely dying you you
think I almost feel like the least
annoying maybe could also be good no
because then he just thinks okay you're
not making this hard on me I can shoot
I'm over for two I'm dying in every
situation you're presenting this is not
but no I wanted to add this the reason
why you can't invite people into the saw
franchise is the same reason why you
can't invite people to start listening
to like Joe Rogan or UFC they know too
much about it yeah actually it's true
you already have heard about it and you
like it oh so they're going in with a
notion one way or the other that's what
I was saying the first one maybe the
first one may the reason why like it's
like that's why I was trying to say it's
like it's not that I think that the saw
franchise is like bad it's just you've
made your choice by now yeah like you
can't I don't think you could say unless
it's like a gen Z person who really has
no idea this thing existed which is a
thing now sure that's yeah I but I I
think that the Saw movies ended up doing
this really well you know we talk about
how they have to amp up the blood and
the guts scares and all that stuff but
like that actually makes the first Saw
movie a great entry point as a tester to
be like hey it's it's a way to dip your
toe or in the case of the first saw your
whole foot into this pool and see if you
like the temperature because if you
don't like that movie it just gets
crazier then you're not then you're not
a saw person way but they still have to
be I think a blank slate on the
franchise for that to work I still think
that there's too much it's become so
like known and parody and like like I
didn't even remember where the franch
was now I was like thinking about I was
like where where did this start where
has it been like just trying to like add
it up I just don't think people would go
into it like well I don't know what this
is let me have an open mind they'd go
into it like is there any way this is
not going to be as stupid as I thought
it you know what I mean like that's yeah
no you're right yeah the other
interesting thing is that uh on on a
kind of different level but but similar
everybody knows who jigsaw is now and
that's the point of the first movie is
you don't know who he is yeah so it's
like if you're watching it for the first
time you're not going to get that same
Pop That all of us got watching that
ending for the first time it's a little
Friday 1 Jason you're guessing who's
killing these kids in the first Friday
the 13th and guy with the hockey mask
right yeah actually it's a reverse in
that regard yeah it's a reverse of this
problem because you can get twisted
watching Friday the 13th because you
think it's you think it's Jason that's
one so this is the reverse of that but
it is a problem you might and you might
be like that movie wasn't as good
because you can't even imagine what it
was like to see that for the first time
unspoiled it was shocking and so if it's
going to be a real tester I think it has
to be a tester on again you just have to
go to a BL like a
child you know what I referenced True
Romance the other day to somebody who
looked at me like I was crazy is that I
was I was like it was in Euphoria like I
am not an elder
Millennial Sydney Sweeney what did you
think she was dressing like and I swear
to God they were like that's what that's
from what wow okay True Romance was a
movie it felt like it was everywhere in
the 90s and people still talk about we
all know what it is but yeah if you
weren't maybe of that time True Romance
might be the movie that might be the
barom of like if it's more popular than
True Romance like if it's pul fiction
people know it they've heard of it if
it's not at least as popular as True
Romance these the the geners many of
whom listen and members of the fresh
ketchup crew 27-year-old I might add
this was not a 22-year-old 22-year-old
I'd be like okay that literally came out
27 27 Oh that's odd I was picturing like
22 no I would have I would have felt a
little bit sad but still I'm like I know
you watch Euphoria yeah and she was like
what is that what that is from yeah this
is like now I'm thinking it's like that
Meme where it's like you know if they
blank they're too young for you bro this
is like if they don't know who's on the
floor in that bathroom she's too young
for you bro wow if they don't know then
then they're too young wow you're now
old enough to see these movies by
yourself allegedly this is the first one
I'll be allowed to see alone are you uh
and that's not age that's actually just
Eric's parents um
because with them they have to be able
to hide your eyes in the right spot
corre where's your anticipation for for
this new like is this one of those
things where every year it's it's
January you're looking at like okay I
gotta I'm seeing this movie in theaters
I'm seeing this opening day it's a Saw
movie every year for you oh I'm I'm day
one I'm Day Zero the the Thursday before
it comes out for any Saw movie and you
know what it's kind of like um it's like
M night shamalan for me another person
that I love but has his hits and misses
a lot of plenty of Misses right but I
will always be there day one to see what
the next thing is because I love I I
just love it all so much and so it's I
think of him I think of Saw as certain
franchises or or or directors whatever
where I'm like you can't lose me you
just can't even if I walk out of the
movie and I don't like it I didn't care
for jigsaw but I couldn't wait for
spiral you know what I mean like uh I'm
I'm ready for the next one no matter
what this one
uh same director I couldn't be more
excited because yes Kevin's back uh and
he gave us six and and uh and he again
it was the editor he is uh maybe you
know obviously James Juan and Leo wiell
did the first uh three movies he James
Juan directed the first one Kevin grer
but again you know edited all of them
yeah up until he D went to the
director's chair his fingerprint all the
things that you think you love about it
like a lot of that is him the editing
the style all that stuff and it's cool
when you see somebody come up through
the where it's like you edited this
movie and
well earned well deserved it's like a
coaching tree in the NFL it's like
you're the offensive coordinator forever
and you might be the genius behind this
team success and now you get your chance
to go out there and prove it which I
feel like after seeing saw six Kevin
grer did and then saw X you mean uh no
no both of them I would say yeah but I
don't want to give anything away about
the new movie but on the subject of the
new movie we actually do have a quick uh
clip it's not going to give anything
away we do have a clip that is just
spoiling no we have this for yeah and
last thing really quick just one line I
host the Rotten Tomatoes podcast it's
called Rotten Tomatoes is wrong uh in
the case of sa 6 the Tomato Meter is
very wrong and our special guest is Eric
strifler he interviewed you came if you
could just to camera tell Eric that's
his favorite Saw movie so if you could
just give Eric a little message about
thanks for you know making saw six you
know your favorite or something like
that hey Eric strifler how are you I
remember you well and uh I've always
appreciated how uh supportive you are of
of s sick so I hope you like this one
all right I think I'm gonna love it sh I
love this guy yes he is he is so sweet
he's wonderful uh and he's he's you can
tell that he's as big of a big a fan as
of the franchise as I am as anybody else
is that's a huge fan he lit up more on
your name than ours so that says
something right there Tomatoes he was
questioning
Eric yes after we cut cameras he did say
that you can stop with a handwritten
letters that he's no longer uh allowing
those to be delivered yeah they do get
returned to C anyways I know I want to
see what your if you can think of the
traps before we uh before we uh close up
shop here your five favorite Saw traps
across the franchise can you rattle them
off is it like you have them ranked five
might take a while because we had Kevin
rank his oh you want
Kevin's he's on the flly name some of
your favorite traps and I'm going to see
if any of these sync up with what Kevin
told us uh I think way up there is the
the key behind the eye trap I'm going to
save my number one for for you know save
it but the key behind the eye uh in at
the the opening of sawu it's just an
unbelievable way to open a sequel are
you kidding me that was like oh we're
not done with this we're we're here
we're ready um I feel like another
another one that drives people crazy
because it's one where it's like I know
how you could have gotten out of that is
also in sawu sawu had some of the best
traps uh the the one where she puts her
hand up into the razors to get the
antidote out of the box but she put up
both mhm and then the you can't come
back down if you just yeah not not
thinking keep your head the needle pit
from satu again so many in sawu are huge
for me I always have to go with because
I mentioned it before you see it get
escaped you see it fail and you see it
succeed the reverse bear trap from the
very first movie yeah it goes all the
way through to saw seven which was at
the time the Final Chapter so it's all
the way through but in saw one she gets
out in saw six he gets out not in the
intended way in the incredible finale
and then in Saw s of course it goes off
so all right I got to go with that one
just because you get everything from it
all the other traps you move on this one
we got to see it all different ways it
was awesome and with that first song
movie that was one of Kevin's favorites
is just Dr Gordon basically having to
make the decision to oh just yeah you
know what funny that movie centered
around that one thing I don't I always
forget that's considered a trap cuz the
whole movie is the Trap as the movies go
on scenes of traps I'm saying yeah the
whole movie is them in the bathroom is a
trap but it's so grandiose that it's
like I always forget that is technically
a trap more a whole escape room he
really liked those guys he gave them he
gave them a lot of little fun things to
do yeah really and and the editing in
that first one like just watching the
decision- making and the flashbacks and
stuff it's like you can see why this guy
would be a great choice to Direct One of
these movies then he had he had two from
sawu he had the furnace and the needle
pit needle pit of course furnace is fun
but needle pit is a classic and then we
go back to heat with uh one of my
favorite traps from this new or the one
that that I just saw for the first time
saw six is oh the the the steam the I
love the steam oh yeah because when I
work everybody knows how that feels my
gym has a steam room Y and I haven't
been in it since seeing this movie he
doesn't want to say the name it's a nice
gym and the steam room I don't know I'm
going to be visiting for a little bit
because uh I love getting in on that
steam but I might take about a week off
from the Steam and then obviously the
carousel too so a lot of great traps you
have any thoughts on on any of the Trap
no I will say like I would just die like
like at the beginning of this one when
she's cutting
off like I got the first twinges of like
some mild arthritic pain and I was
literally like chop it off if you you
give me something I really feel like I
could hack through like I'm not going to
torture myself for three minutes or
whatever just for the sake of like
giving an effort if I think I can
actually get through other guy did he
cut off little pieces yeah right that's
like man I can't wait for you to see the
new one yeah okay I am so excited for
the new one uh in Kevin We Trust I'm
ready there you go all right so we are
going to uh transition to our close
outro here and you do want to stay tuned
because Eric has a very fun thing if
you're in the New York area here a
couple weeks hit the music
[Music]
Brian is that where you live I live in a
van I think I might have mentioned that
he literally lives in a van right that's
right but New York is home B I'm from
New York so I do know that I you know
that yes yeah hey kids you want to go to
a haunted house curated by a guy who
lives in a van well you can do that I
don't have a mustache it's fine okay
tell us about this this haunted house
thing you got going yeah so it's called
uh nictofobia um we we kind of changed
the name a few years ago to to synthetic
presents nicop phobia but I think we're
kind of going back to the original name
uh but um it's nicop phobia it which is
the fear of the dark and uh every year
is a different show started doing it in
2010 my my career in this field really
started in 2004 so almost 20 years ago
where I started acting in these kind of
things then I went on to creating my own
scenes and then branching off and
creating my own whole exhibit and back
then more of a haunted house now more of
a theatrical like immersive experience
um it's not it's not like people jumping
out at you and stuff like that so we we
always want to make that clear to people
it's not like chainsaws and clowns and
stuff it's more um spooky uh and fun um
I always say it's important to give fun
because like I was saying before with
the horror um genre you don't know what
scares people so we'll give you some
scares but we'll also make sure you have
fun if you're not the type to get scared
then we want to at least give you a good
time so it's fun it's spooky it is scary
um but yeah not people jumping out and
stuff like that it's more like storyline
trying to like solve some Clues and
stuff um and uh yeah it's really fun
October 13th 14th and 15th we're doing
one weekend only we haven't done it
since 2016 uh because I moved into my
van really I moved into my van and I was
on the road and then there was Co and
now we're like it's time to bring it
back so we're dipping our toes back into
the water um with one weekend only and
you just so happened to have uh possibly
jacqu and myself both in New York City
that weekend very interesting I have
shows y'all can Cod to in New York
October 12th and 13th I'll be headlining
at New York comedy club you can get
tickets at Mark ellis. live thanks to
everybody came to see me in Vegas by the
way some new tour dates including Boston
next year are going to be announced soon
um Jacqueline are we going to this thing
in New York like would you do so you
heard the pitch yeah I think the pitch
is really great I am going to moderate a
panel with a guy that knows a little bit
about a horror Mr Jason Blum he'll be
there with the new BR bring he'd love it
I'm on their dollar so I don't know
exactly what Mr BL he can get his
tickets at synthetic. NC he would go I
have no problem about him going but I'm
not going to be the one to say no it
mean it honestly I think it might work
out it depends on like what I have going
on but just the fact that I'm there is
crazy enough so is that the same weekend
as ComiCon then I guess oh per that's
perfect I feel like that's a good
crossover crowd I mean it now it seems
like Destiny it seems like fate I might
have to put some promo up at the at the
con I have to like put some posters up
or something but if you are going to be
at Comic Con you should um come to the
universal Exorcist panel and see me come
say hi tell me that you like the podcast
if you listen to it you see Jack when
moderate you can come get some Giggles
with me and then let Eric uh scare the
crap out of you in a fun way in a fun
way in a fun well if you really want
Eric to scare the crap out of you that's
going to be this coming weekend where he
will once again be dusting off his
legendary karaoke chop which you can
hear I have my full voice for sure right
now yeah I'm not I'm not a little asked
be from uh My Best Friend's Wedding this
past weekend at all trying to recover so
that's watch the show to find out if I
did recover that's the that's the pitch
get some vocal rest you'll be fine right
now yeah this is my vocal rest the
Wanger show they do karaoke uh on an
annual basis I believe sometimes uh more
karaoke opportunities crop up with those
knuckleheads you never know one of which
may or may not be producing the show
right now so good luck with that and
anything else you got going on you want
to recommend anything else for the kids
out there they should be watching around
this time time of year oh gosh you know
what uh around this time of year yeah I
guess it's spooky time I'll tell you
what my so we're just talking about
scary but fun uh my my favorite types of
movies to watch around this time are
Halloween movies not necessarily horror
movies doesn't need to be scary as long
as it's got that Halloween Vibe and my
number one for that is and it's a little
spooky it's but it's like an RL Stein
joint kind of deal uh when good ghouls
go bad oh okay yes it's a it was on ABC
Family back in the day and again if she
doesn't know what ABC family is she's
too young for you
bro uh ABC
does she know what true romance is
that's my cut up yeah it was like a TV
movie and it's just got the perfect
Halloween Vibe and it's fantastic you
know like so Hocus Pocus isn't scary but
it's Halloween like the worst the worst
witch in Return to Oz are my movies like
that there was some made for TV joint
with like R McClanahan in it and a bunch
of goblins I can't remember but it was
adorable yeah nice spoky time kind of
feel you know you go you're looking for
for the Halloween Vibe cuz you know it's
not usually it's if it's Halloween it
must be saw but now it's if it's back to
school it must be saw really cuz it's
September they didn't capitalize on by
the way sawale uh so now if it's
Halloween it must be when good goals go
bad maybe I'll start that hashtag see
I'm I'm getting into the not I mean I
always like the hor and I'm never like a
Halloween costume guy I'm lighting a lot
of pumpkin spice candles really in C
Caucasian getting into it it makes me
feel like football that's what I is it
because I'm white is that why I'm doing
it a white person like in PSL okay he's
like at the doctor just give it to me
straight is it cuz I'm white
oh man to stra this whole time I thought
I was evolving as an adult and it's like
no you finally fell into the Trap that
all white like let me guess you liked
that show in the 90s that had Ross and
Rachel like that's where it is PS I
watched a lot of friends inas a lot of
friends in Vegas cuz I was being a good
boy and went back to my room after the
show every night um jacqu is going to be
at New York comedy uh new I'm going to
she might be New York comedy club I'm
going to do five minutes she's going to
go to New York Comic con and do some
moderating so check out all of her
exploits on social media as well for
Eric striffler Jaclyn Coley our whole
team behind the scenes here I am Mark
Els go to Rotten tomatoes.com for all
the latest and greatest in the world of
movies TV everything in between and next
week Jacqueline big big episode a movie
that I have never seen before I can't
believe you haven't seen this movie
before but I really appreciate that we
were bringing two black women to a movie
that only brought one it's the craft
ladies and gentlemen few pumpkin spice C
Y and I think we're going to have a
special guest it's going to be awesome
this is going to be so great this is
going to be so great it's a fun time of
year for all of us here at Rotten
Tomatoes to all of you out there
listening thanks do all the rate review
all that good stuff wherever you enjoy
this podcast make us part of your week
or bi-weekly or whenever you see a new
episode crop up we love hearing from you
can write Us Rotten Tomatoes is wrong is
the name of the show RT is wrong at
Rotten tomatoes.com is the email address
and with that we will say thank you good
night good luck
and uh do you want to it's not do you
want to play a game I'd like to play a
game uh oh yes there will be reviews
there will be review oh my gosh we'll
see y'all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week